Hey youtubers it's charlie and this week was
another double episode of Korra.
So this video is going to be for Episodes
5 and 6.
The first one was the conclusion of the Beifong
Metal Bending Clan story and the second episode
was the beginning of a new Airbender arc up
at the Northern Temple.
Who else almost threw up a little when they
revealed the final fate of the Earth King's
bear Bosco.
I'm not a member of PETA or anything either
but something about Sky Bison jackets makes
me so angry.
Hello new people, if you're just finding me
for the first time I do Weekly Korra videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'm also doing a special Comic Con giveaway
I'll explain at the end of this video.
So since this video is for two episodes I'm
going to do top 10 WTF moments and then I'll
do my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen them
yet.
I'll wait just a sec....Okay, here we go.
Number 10 - Beifong Acupuncture
This was the climax of the Beifong v Beifong
episode.
I was fairly satisfied with the way they explained
Lin's hatred of Suyin even if they skipped
a lot of things.
Like Toph retiring and Lin never agreeing
to meet up with her again.
It sounds like Toph was pretty active in everyone's
lives up till the events on Legend Of Korra.
She was around while Opal was growing up,
and I know a lot of you are still confused.
But she's not dead, Toph is just listed as
whereabouts unknown.
There's no promise that she'll be back this
year.
Maybe in book 4 or maybe just in the comics.
But, Number 9 - Bolin versus Metalbending
It was awesome to see Korra pick up so fast.
I don't know that I believe she's the first
avatar to ever metal bend.
It's possible but does Suyin know the complete
history of the Avatar lineage?
I don't think so.
Bolin learning to do it will take longer,
but I feel like the language Suyin used is
teasing that he will learn eventually.
This season is moving pretty fast, so I wouldn't
be surprised if it happened in the next one
or two episodes.
His path to learning Metal bending and overcoming
his self doubt is just like Opal's.
So I think they'll both achieve their bending
goals at the same time.
It would be really cool to see them do a combo
metal and airbend move in a battle.
Like classic Fire Ferrets style combo attack.
Moving on to Number 8 - Brand New Beifong
It took me a minute to get used to the new
Lin.
Beifong Kale Smoothie kind of made me hungry
too.
She's not super hippy dippy or anything now,
she's just mellowed out.
She reminds me of early Toph, punching her
problems away.
The thing that really threw me off was seeing
her smile.
And not in an ironic way.
Did anyone else get a Joo Dee vibe from last
airbender.
Like she was almost too pleasant when she
stepped out of her room.
I don't think anything funky is going on,
she just took her grumpy pants off.
Number 7 - Lin Versus Suyin Fight
I feel like they gave this match the same
emotional weight and brutality you'd see with
Aang and Firelord Ozai or Azula and Zuko.
No one was pulling any punches.
If they really wanted to hurt each other though,
they'd be exclusively metalbending.
The kind of blunt force trauma damage big
rocks do is way harder to sneak on another
earth bender than a really unpredictable cable
strike or lead projectile.
It was more like a good old fashioned street
brawl like you'd see in a classic western
movie.
Which is funny, because Bumi's Airbender posse
felt like it was straight out of an old John
Wayne movie.
I did think it was really cool they let Opal,
the airbender be the calming force.
Airbending is all about peace and tranquility,
so of course the best mediators would be airbenders.
I saw an interesting theory some of you guys
were talking about last week.
That Opal is secretly Lin's daughter.
I don't think that's the case, but I think
Aunt Lin will be a much bigger part of the
family going forward.
Number 6 - Bumi Tells Tenzin to Go All Full
Metal Jacket On the Recruits
I loved listening to JK Simmons do his best
Tenzin as R Lee Ermey impression.
When really it's Meelo that's the crazy drill
sergeant.
Even though Episode was all airbenders it
felt like Tenzin was the least important person.
It was really all about the new airbenders
coming together
There was one thing he said that struck me
as possibly really important for the future.
At the beginning of the Obstacle Course he
said the Key is to maintain your heaven and
earth connection.
The Guru Laghima pendant got mentioned and
even though he just made a mental note about
it I'm wondering if they're teeing up Zaheer's
plot, about learning Laghima's secrets.
Number 5 - Airbender Ninja Warrior Obstacle
Course
This was too much fun.
I don't watch America Ninja Warrior a lot
but just the idea of an obstacle course sounds
awesome.
And Meelo with the Watermelon gun and that
evil evil smile.
I want a watermelon gun at my next party.
I'm way too old for summer camp, but did any
of you ever do obstacle courses at camp?
I never had to do one as crazy as the airbender
course, but there were monkey bars that hung
over a pool we had to get across.
This all teed up the Jinora story.
Number 4 - Jinora wants her Tattoos
her argument to Kai was that she has attained
mastery over airbending and the sub form.
As well as a deep connection to the spirits,
but without the tattoos you're just a pretender.
I heard it's a similar thing in Russian Prisons,
like there you're tattoos are supposed to
tell your life story, so the more things you've
done, the more tattoos you have.
So if you ran into someone without any, it
means they're a nobody, they're nothing because
they have no life story.
Thematically there are a lot of cultures that
use markings as a way to denote mastery or
maturity.
Even though I think Jinora will be a full
on master by the end of this season, I don't
think she'll get tattoos yet.
Avatar Yanchen is the most notable female
master airbender I can think of.
That's pretty much what a grown up Jinora
would look like.
They don't completely shave their heads like
the men.
Number 3 - Team Zaheer Goes After Korra
Lavabending escape for the win.
I love how Zaheer used the Guru Pathik chakra
technique of going into that astral state
of meditation where you can sense the energy
of other beings.
He has clearly done his homework.
I think there are a couple scenarios he could
be going for.
Either he's trying to bring back Guru Laghima
somehow or energy bend himself into Korra's
body.
Or achieve some secret technique of Laghima
that we haven't seen yet.
The two part finale is called Enter the Void
and Venom of the Red Lotus, The Void talk
just makes me think of the astral state when
Aang and Korra were learning to energy bend.
But now it sounds like they're heading for
the Metal Clan.
Number 2 - Sky Bison Rescue
I loved watching Bumi rally the other airbenders
and that the Wild Sky Bison zoomed in to rescue
the others.
For a minute I thought that Jinora would get
captured by the Earth Queen again.
Did anyone else feel like Bumi and Boom Joom
were a joke making fun of Han Solo and Chewbacca.
Like when the other bender called him on being
able to speak the same language as Boom Joom
and he just waved his hand and trailed off.
I feel like that's totally Han Solo and Chewie.
I already had a feeling the wild sky bison
were going to be a big part of the plot.
My first theory before the end of the episode
was that Meelo would do his crazy animal whispering
trick and tame them all in like fifteen minutes.
Let me know if you think he could actually
do that.
It doesn't matter now, they're completely
pacified.
Time for a sky bison tutorial episode.
but my Number 1 WTF Moment - The Earth Queen
Ate Her Father's Pet Bear Bosco
This made me a little upset.
Because yes, it's supposed to be a joke, but
she's crazy enough to do something like that.
And Sky Bison veal, that's enough to make
anyone go vegan.
I only noticed it when they were kicking his
ass, but the leader who totally sounded like
Clancy Brown.
The guy who played Long Feng in last airbender.
He was wearing a sky bison pelt.
Kai's takedown was probably intended to be
a Tenzin Kai moment of clarity, but I really
wanted Kai to go too far and stab him with
the glider stick.
In defense of the episode, that would have
been totally out of character for an airbender.
But it would have looked pretty cool.
Kai is actually a really proficient bender,
I have a feeling he'll learn Jinora's spirit
bending technique by the end of this season.
But let me know what your biggest WTF moment
was and do you think the Earth Queen really
ate Bosco?
It sounds like she totally did given how awful
she is and all the other exotic animals she
eats.
Overall I gave episode 6 a B plus and Episode
7 an A minus.
I just thought the airbender episode moved
the real plot forward.
The Guru Laghima story along with Team Zaheer.
They were like the connective tissue between
the arcs.
And even though the episodes were from separate
two parters, I didn't feel disconnected.
I can't wait to see Bolin Metalbend.
He and Bumi are still the Korra Class Clowns,
but they both got some really good moments.
Bumi's speech was actually one of the better
Korra speeches I've heard this season.
And then to pay off the Family of Aang bit
with him finally feeling like part of the
Air Nation was important.
I'm interested to see if he ever does shave
his head.
He's a long ways from getting his tattoos,
but for some reason I just can't picture him
bald.
Speaking of Bald, a lot of people are commenting
on the similarities between Kai and Aang.
I do think they share a lot of character DNA,
but I don't think Kai's backstory will overlap
with the Avatar's.
It is
possible that Team Zaheer has some familial
connection to the main characters, I know
everyone wanted Zaheer and P'Li to be related
to Mako and Bolin.
But let me know what your craziest Team Zaheer
theories are and here's the details on my
comic con giveaway.
If you didn't see it earlier I'm giving away
a pabu plush doll.
This is in addition to the regular giveaway.
So all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
I'll be at comic con so I'll upload the Korra
Panel.
That's going to be next friday.
They're doing two more episodes so I'll try
to get a review out that night.
But it might be Saturday morning.
There's a lot of stuff going down.
Right now click here to learn all about the
new Airbending Sub form and click here for
my episode 4 and 5 video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!